after the disappointment of the Black
Cauldron Disney suddenly got on this
huge kick not only were they gonna turn
out better products but they were gonna
turn them out fast
the films went from coming out every
five to seven to even ten years to
suddenly every year and the film that
sparked the Disney golden era the
revolutionary film that started hit
after hit after hit again The Little
Mermaid yeah you all know it you've all
seen it and now we're gonna talk about
it is there any point in comparing it to
the Hans Christian Andersen story I mean
we all know she doesn't die in the end
Disney wouldn't do that if I hell I
think they couldn't do that so much like
Oliver and company let's just keep it to
the content as is this is the first film
in a long time where the animation was
actually looking like Disney animation
again this was the return to the fairy
tale the smooth lines the nice songs the
beautiful backgrounds all the stuff that
started with Snow White and most people
think of when they hear the word Disney
the story is about Ariel a 16 year old
girl who's obsessed with being on dry
land
her father forbids it but then she falls
in love with a handsome prince after
saving his life she decides that she
absolutely wants to become human so that
she can be with him so she sells her
voice to Ursula the sea witch and gets
herself a pair of legs the only downside
is she can't tell the prince who she is
which means she has to start from
scratch in order to win him over of
course while the sea witch is plotting
her way to get control of the underworld
or other water world the feedback I get
from this movie is fascinating and not
actually from guys believe her or not
but from women I find the either love or
hate this movie and all of it centers
around the main character Ariel but
we'll get to that in a second let's look
at the good stuff the music you know it
in and out it's Alan Menken songs and
man are they memorable catchy as hell
they're bouncy they're fun they're slow
their romantic their diabolical he gets
the tone just right the comic relief
they're also fun
there's a fun Tibbits with the crab you
have Buddy Hackett as the seagull
there's the crazy a chef voiced by odo
it's pretty good the animation top-notch
this is the animation people want to see
from Disney for a while and men didn't
blow people away it still blows me away
watching it today looking at these
angles look at the colors everything it
just pops the villain is great
what's like Ratigan she just so enjoys
what she's doing although it's much more
of a revenge fest that it is just to be
evil so maybe her plot is a little bit
more motivation and I like the fact this
was the first Disney film where the
couple actually had to build their
romance from something they didn't just
meet and suddenly love each other
well okay they meet they love each other
but at the same time they have to meet
and they have to work at it again it's
not like Snow White where they meet and
they get married or Sleeping Beauty
where they meet they sing and suddenly
they're involved there is some
development here even though it did take
what three days well okay the Disney
verse that was a long time but let's get
to what most women either love or hate
The Little Mermaid herself Carrie
okay so what's bad about her she is
whiny even her nice song as we get down
to it is just very pretty whining she
certainly has all the typical
sixteen-year-old cliches like hating her
father talking about boys wanting good
for her life away for them but let's be
honest that's kind of typical for a lot
of girls tell me that that's why some
women hate it I mean I guess Bella's
living out a lot of girls with fantasies
too but doesn't necessarily make her a
good character but she definitely has a
passion and a drive that sets her apart
from a lot of the other Disney one she's
a hopeless romantic but she's also
determined when she wants something
she'll go to whatever lengths it takes
to get it so for the most part I thought
a lot of the backlash about the
character was just sort of nitpicking
but then I watched Lindsey's review and
she brought this up she doesn't really
change she doesn't learn anything
Ariel wants something there are
obstacles she gets what she wants the
end yeah that's a really good point
despite her causing all this trouble she
still gets exactly what she wants she
whines and complains and in the end
she's rewarded for it but you could make
a very slim argument that once they have
her and she's apologizing that she has
acknowledged she made a mistake
that admittedly she should have dot but
the scene is two seconds long and they
don't know she gets her way anyway at
the end so it doesn't really matter I
guess there are some major character
flaws with her so why the lights to
enjoy her well
horrible to say I actually really like
it when she can't talk yeah I know make
whatever women should speak joke you
want but that's not the reason I like it
I like it because her curiosity comes
out in full blue she isn't complaining
here she's enjoying she's in heaven
seeing all these new things
she's a wanderer she's an explorer she
likes discovering things and no where
does that come out clearer in just the
simple expressions and the great
animation here even her songs which are
sing complaining I guess actually really
do show how she feels about a situation
then is very passionate so I guess
that's what a lot of people really do
get behind it this way
so yeah deconstructing childhoods aside
how does this film holder well I guess
it has the ethical flaws that a lot of
people say are just ethical flaws and
Disney films in general you know just
meeting a person a day wanting to Miriam
not always dealing with the consequences
of your actions but the stuff that's
good is really friggin good the music
like I said outstanding some of the best
the animation stellar the comic relief
memorable the villain awesome
even the father character a character
that usually gets tossed aside in most
Disney movies is actually pretty
well-developed here and our main
characters despite their flaws still
have a lot of things you can like about
personally I still really enjoy it it
has its issues but the good stuff is
just too damn good and this would only
be the first monster hit that would set
Disney on a